Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Sag mal, Linus, wo siehst du dich eigentlich in fünf Jahren?
Wo ist ja schon optimistisch. Die Frage ist, ob...
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 560 vom 16. September 2026 und wir haben die Zukunft fest im Blick,
aber es stellt sich langsam eine Sehschwäche ein.
Genau, der Blick ist halt, der Blick ist halt.
Werden die goldenen 20er nochmal liefern? Das ist die große Frage.
Das ist wie früher, weißt du, wenn du so 3D-Shooter mit nicht ganz so wilden
Grafikkarten, wo dann auch alles im Nebel untergegangen ist,
weil der nicht so weit rendern wollte. Und wir haben halt auch nicht mehr,
die GPUs sind ja alle weg.
Die werden ja von anderen gekauft.
Ja. Heute wollen wir ein bisschen über die Zukunft reden.
Denn in ihr gedenken wir zu leben.
Ja, die macht sich ja eigentlich, sagen wir mal so, perspektivisch macht die
sich ja immer besser als die Gegenwart. Die ist einfach so unglaublich vergänglich.
Zukunft hält ja eigentlich relativ lang. Hatte man zumindest bisher mal so den Eindruck.
Gibt jetzt allerdings so ein paar Entwicklungen.
Da wollen wir drüber sprechen.
Wo ich jetzt auch nicht mehr so genau weiß, was man jetzt eigentlich noch dazu sagen soll. Naja.
Ganz kurzes Feedback vorne weg.
Und André korrigiert, das Gericht, was Linus als internationales Gericht für
Menschenrechte bezeichnet hat, nennt sich selbst International Criminal Court
auf Deutsch, Internationaler Strafgerichtshof.
Ja. Gerichte für Menschenrechte kenne ich in der Geschmacksrichtung Europäischer
Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte. Ja, scheiße.
Gericht, ein Gericht für Menschenrechte. Was ist ein Gericht für Menschenrechte? Falafel.
Ja, sehr inklusiv. Und lecker auch.
Verlaufen ist eins.
Genau. Mehr Korrekturen gibt es nicht. Alles andere, was wir gesagt haben, ist wahr.
Uneingeschränkt.
Eine, dann finden wir normalerweise Event-Ankündigungen machen wir ja immer
am Ende der Sendung. Werden auch heute ein wichtiges Event.
Zwei wichtige Events noch am Ende der Sendung ankündigen. Aber ein Event,
was bei uns immer besondere Berücksichtigungen findet, obwohl man es gar nicht
mehr ankündigen muss, weil ja alle wissen, dass es vom 27.
Bis 30. Dezember stattfindet, ist der Chaos Communication Congress. Die 40. Iteration.
In Hamburg. Und da wurde jetzt das Motto und die unterschiedlichen Calls for
Participation, Content, Art, Punk und Music veröffentlicht.
Das heißt, ihr könnt euch da jetzt mit euren Vorträgen, Workshops,
Kunst, Punk, Musik, Gestaltung oder auch Band, DJ und was nicht alles,
bewerben im Prinzip, in die Diskussion einbringen, an diesem Event was beizutragen.
Und ich kann mich nur herzlich dazu einladen, bitte mach mir eine Freude.
Und macht gut verständliche Einreichungen,
aus denen so wirklich auch hervorgeht, was da passieren wird.
Weil das erleichtert einfach die Bewertungen, die wir natürlich dann mit einer KI machen.
Die Einreichungen auch.
Denn, genau.
Ich wollte jetzt hier gerade eine Überleitung zum Motto machen.
Denn wir sind ja Model Citizens.
Und das ist das Motto des diesjährigen Kongress, das ich wieder besonders gelungen
finde. Weil Model Citizens natürlich so,
ein Spiel ist mit den vorbildlichen Bürgern. Also der Model Citizen ist also
der besonders toller, braver, vorbildlicher Bürger.
Also einer immer wählt, aber nicht AfD.
Genau und was machen wir noch alles ne,
Was macht ein braver Bürger?
Fährt nicht mit dem Fahrrad offen.
Genau, nur bei Grün.
Überfällt keine Banken.
Ja, gut, oder nicht so viele.
Insgesamt so, sag ich mal, keine weiße Weste, aber ein weißes Hemd.
Aber natürlich auch eine wunderschöne Anspielung, oder eben das Vorspiel mit,
den Models, den Large Language Models und KI-Modellen,
die ja sicherlich bald auch eine zunehmende Rolle in unserer Gesellschaft spielen.
Und deswegen finde ich dieses Motto mal wieder besonders gelungen.
Das kann ich sagen, weil ich überhaupt nicht an dessen Schöpfung beteiligt war.
Das war mal wieder Erdgeist und ich finde es wirklich besonders schön.
Unter dem Motto Model Citizens wollen wir gemeinsam neue Modelle für eine Gesellschaft
suchen, nachdem die bisherigen modellhaften Bürgerinnen den Planeten in zweifelhaften
Zustand hinterlassen haben.
Also viele Perspektiven auf dieses Motto und ich hoffe, dass das für euch auch,
inspirierend ist und ihr eure Agenten reichhaltige Submissions,
zum CSP machen lassen.
Bitte nicht irgendeinen KI-Agenten da drauf hetzen.
Die verabreden sich dann nur zum Hacken, kaufen Tickets und kommen am Ende nicht, weißt du?
Immer das Gleiche mit denen.
Ja, Kraftwerk hat es ja schon wieder Jahre vorhergesagt.
Ja.
Sie ist ein Model und sie sieht gut aus. Ich nehme sie gerne zu mir nach Hause.
Das ist der Wunsch nach lokalen Modellen.
Das Modell, ja.
Ach ja, genau. Also das ist der Kongress. Es gibt einen Call for Participation.
Es gibt einen Call for Content. Einen Call for Art. Es gibt einen Call for Punk.
Das ist der Punk-Spielteam, ne? Also Programm am Punk-Spielteam.
Und for Music.
Ja.
Also ihr könnt Musikwünsche...
Nee, ihr müsst die Musikwünsche...
Ich wünsch mir Frogger.
Ihr müsst die Musikwünsche öffnen. ihr müsst die Musikwünsche inspirieren,
ihr müsst dafür sorgen, dass sich eure Musik gewünscht wird.
Ja. So.
Dann kommen wir mal dazu, was du in fünf Jahren machst. Wo sehen sie sich in fünf Jahren? Genau.
Flog gerade so ein schönes Meme-Bild, wo dann einer auf dem Rücken lag und mit
einer Knarre auf den Roboter schoss.
Das müsste ein Terminator sein, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Terminator war, das Bild, um ehrlich zu sein.
Aber es wäre eine kulturell naheliegend,
den einen Film, der mit der Übernahme einer künstlichen Intelligenz spielt,
quasi als erstes in den 80er Jahren die dystopische Science-Fiction in diesem
Bereich dann losgetreten hat,
nicht die Primärquelle zu nutzen.
Findest du, wie ist denn der Film bei dir so niedergeregnet,
als du den das erste Mal gesehen hast?
Terminator? Ey, war ich viel zu jung. Fand ich natürlich irgendwie super irre,
wollte der Terminator sein und mir so ein Auge rausnehmen und so weiter.
Was, echt?
Habe ich dann nicht gemacht, aber habe dann auf dem Computer versucht,
künstliche Intelligenz in einer Kette aus If-Ben-Konstrukten herbeizuführen.
Hab da schon gemerkt, wenn künstliche Intelligenz, dann muss sie mir überlegen
sein, weil ich hab's ja nicht hingekriegt.
Der Terminator, der hat natürlich bei mir wirklich alle Register gefüllt.
Der erste oder der zweite?
Der erste schon. Und zwar aus einem bestimmten Grund.
Also abgesehen davon, dass die Story ja an sich sehr cool ist,
also es ist ja so Robot Uprising, die Menschheit wird unterdrückt.
Und es gibt aber einen Widerstandskämpfer, John Connor, der halt dann den Robots mal richtig ordentlich,
Ärger bereitet, woraufhin die dann eine Zeitmaschine bauen und damit einen Roboter
zurückschicken, nämlich Arnold Schwarzenegger, eben diesen Terminator,
der dann die Mutter umbringen soll, damit dieser Widerstandskämpfer gar nicht erst geboren wird.
Und dann gibt es so geile Szenen, wo so der Terminator so durch die Gegend läuft
und du siehst alles so aus seiner Perspektive, also aus so einer Kameraperspektive.
Das wollte ich nämlich auch haben, ja. Das wollte ich auch haben.
Und ich saß so im Kino und sehe das so und auf einmal macht es so,
und dann läuft so Programmcode von oben nach unten. Und weißt du, was das war?
Wahrscheinlich Basic oder so?
Nein. 6502 Maschinencode. Der Code, den ich damals auf C64 programmiert habe.
Und ich dachte mir, geil, das kann ich auch. Ich kann auch so einen Roboter programmieren.
Und wie haben sie das geschafft, den Terminator mit dem 6502 zu steuern? Ja, ja.
Nee, also das war natürlich,
ein bemerkenswerter Film, auch weil er so günstig produziert wurde,
aber halt einfach so gnadenlos eingeschlagen hat damals.
Das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen. Das war einfach mal wirklich dann so
eine neue Vorlage auch für die Sci-Fi. Und jetzt sind wir auf einmal in so einer
Situation, wo eben diese Softwaretechnik sich so weiterentwickelt hat.
Dass auf einmal all diese Dinge unfassbar real wirken. Auf der einen Seite haben
wir natürlich jetzt diese offensichtliche
AI-Entwicklung, über die wir ja schon viel gesprochen haben.
Dann rieseln jetzt in zunehmendem Maße diese Videos aus den USA und China rein,
wo so humanoide Roboter mittlerweile ziemlich bemerkenswerte Dinge tun.
Hast du diese chinesische Roboter-Olympiade gesehen, die sie da vor einem Monat
abgehalten haben, wo sie so alle möglichen Disziplinen mit humanoiden Robotern ausspielen?
Also die laufen dann schnell, machen Weitsprung, Boxen.
Ach so, einen habe ich hier letztens auch bei so einem Event gesehen.
Der hat die ganze Zeit so Karate und solche Sachen, Salto rückwärts und sowas.
Alles mögliche.
Voller Angeber, also wirklich unnötig.
Naja, es ist auf jeden Fall ganz interessant. Es hat das zweite Mal stattgefunden
und wenn man sich die Videos vom ersten Event anschaut und die Videos vom zweiten
Event merkt man, dass die Fortschritte signifikant sind,
und dann gab es ja ein bisschen Aufregung, weil sie es dann geschafft haben
mit einem Roboter die 100 Meter Sprint schneller zu laufen als Usain Bolt.
Wobei man sagen muss, Usain Bolt war definitiv besser im Bremsen.
Die sind nämlich einfach alle hinten gegen die Wand gelaufen beziehungsweise
das war schon so eine Matte aber trotzdem ist die Hälfte dabei irgendwie zerplatzt und explodiert,
naja, also auf jeden Fall noch einiges zu holen nur man merkt eben wie jetzt
diese Softwaretechnologie und,
die Hardwaretechnologie da
ganz gut zusammenkommt man kann sich auf einmal ganz gut vorstellen dass,
naja, sowas wie ein Terminator ja,
zumindest jetzt technisch möglich ahnbar wird.
Weil damals so da schützt uns natürlich dann.
Also der wird die KI ja nicht on board haben, das heißt, da schützt uns dann
das deutsche Mobilfunknetz noch.
Aber sonst der wird das dann auch irgendwann on board haben, gar keine Frage. Ja.
Wenn er sich den Rahmen leisten kann.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, das ist, sagen wir mal, die plumpe Vision, die ja dann auch,
im Westen ja auch sehr negativ bewertet wird.
Ja, immer diese negativ, weißt du? Diese, ne, was Neues?
Menschvernichtung, boah, sind wir jetzt auch das? Dann auch wieder scheiße, ja?
Ich meine so generell, also du hast ja in westlichen Gesellschaften ist ja der
Blick auf diese Menschmaschine eher negativ.
Frankenstein, all diese ganzen Dinge sind immer so Dystopien im westlichen Kontext.
Während du jetzt im asiatischen Raum, wenn du mal schaust, wie die Japaner drauf
blicken, für die ist halt so ein humanoider Roboter erstmal ein Freund. Das ist Assistent.
Bei uns gab es so eine positive Erzählung eigentlich selten.
In Japan war das schon vor 20 Jahren so, dass die immer so gedacht haben,
ja, toll, humanoide Roboter, die können dann den alten Leuten im Altersheim
irgendwie helfen und in deinem Haushalt helfen.
Und in westlich geprägten Gesellschaften war das nie so. Da war eigentlich immer die Angst vorneweg.
Jetzt kann man natürlich drüber diskutieren, welche dieser beiden Sichtweisen da angemessener ist.
Tatsache ist, die Technologie entwickelt sich weiter und sie tut es derzeit
eben mit einer Geschwindigkeit, die ist bemerkenswert.
Und,
die ist bemerkenswert. Und bei bisherigen technologischen,
Entwicklungen, da war dann so einmal der Sprung, dann war die Technologie da.
Was weiß ich, Motor, Dampfmaschine,
oder Nuklearenergie nutzen oder so,
die ist dann da, da ist dann auch ein unmittelbarer Sprung, die Welt ist,
nicht mehr wie sie mal war oder so und dann wird aber die Technologie selber
nach diesem Sprung die entwickelt sich dann ich sag mal so ein bisschen linear weiter.
Und erhält nach und nach Einzug in die Veränderung der Gesellschaft und der Wirtschaft und Und,
ich denke, was hier jetzt eben der Durchbruch war, eben eine selbstlernende Technologie.
Und der Kern von diesen KIs ist ja, dass sie Dinge lernen.
Und das eben relativ gut. Und wenn der Sprung ist, dass du eine Technologie
hast, die etwas lernen kann, dann ist natürlich auch davon auszugehen,
dass sie mehr lernen wird.
Oder immer mehr mit dieser Technologie gelernt wird, verbessert wird und sonst
was. Und deswegen würde ich sagen, ist hier quasi auch die Entwicklung,
die Weiterentwicklung der Technologie,
Entgegen aller Annahmen, die ja bisher immer von so einem linearen Verständnis,
ja, das kann irgendwann einmal, oh, aber jetzt, jetzt ist ja langsam ein Plateau
erreicht und oh, scheiße, hinter mir.
Und ich denke, das ist schon ein fundamentaler Unterschied.
Es kann natürlich immer noch irgendwo ein Ressourcenmangel oder eine fundamentale,
Grenze dieser Lernentwicklung eintreten,
aber es ist zumindest erstmal in der Weiterentwicklung für mich erstmal intuitiv,
verständlich, dass hier eben eine exponentielle Weiterentwicklung stattfindet, statt eine...
Genau. Und vor allem, weil halt diese Maschinen lernen können.
Das heißt, sie können dann auch lernen zu lernen. Lernen in zunehmendem Maße von sich selbst.
Und irgendwann trainieren sie sich vielleicht halt auch selbst.
So, was derzeit wird ja, sagen wir mal, der Fortschrift schon noch durch Entwickler
vorangetrieben, die dann Ideen haben, wie man es noch besser kombinieren kann,
sich dabei sicherlich auch schon von ihren eigenen AIs helfen lassen.
Und es ist absehbar, dass wir eben Systeme haben, die so ein gewisses,
ich will jetzt nicht Bewusstsein sagen, also eine Bauernschleue auf jeden Fall
entwickeln, mit denen sie sich ihre eigenen Strategien zurechtlegen und das
ist ja auch genau das, was wir jetzt in den letzten Tagen und Wochen,
gesehen haben, vor allem im Security-Bereich.
Ja, ich würde das, also ich verstehe das immer so viel, der Security-Bereich,
dieser Hacking-Bereich wird immer so viel, so besonders gewertet,
weil so, oh, die Hacking, ja.
Und das ist natürlich auch was Besonderes, zumal sie es irgendwie in einer beeindruckenden
Art und Weise gemacht haben.
Ich denke aber, man muss das mal, ich würde Hacking eher nur als eine besonders
ausgeprägte Form der Lösungsorientierung sehen.
Ja, dass du sagst, aha, hier ist etwas, das möchte ich lösen,
hier ist mein Zielzustand, hier ist der Weg dahin und jetzt,
mache ich halt, was notwendig ist und ich finde es verhältnismäßig.
Dass eben solche besonders fähigen Modelle mit einem immer noch ziemlich beschränkten Kontext,
also intuitiv verständlich, dass sie sich eben auf die möglichen Lösungen konzentrieren,
und die eben verfolgen, insbesondere in Code.
Wir hatten ja in einer der vergangenen Sendungen schon ein bisschen erarbeitet,
klar, es gibt einfach Unmengen an Code,
den man nutzen kann, um KIs zu trainieren und Code hat die Eigenschaft,
dass er kommentiert ist und die Eigenschaft, dass wir ihn in Repositories ablegen,
die seine Versionsgeschichte abbilden.
Und wenn Daten in dieser Form vorliegen, kannst du nicht nur eben Programmieren
daran lernen, sondern eben auch, was wird im Laufe der Zeit verbessert,
mit anderen Worten, was mache ich beim nächsten Mal gleich richtig?
Also was war mal die Idee, was sind die Fehler, die unterwegs gemacht wurden,
und wie vermeide ich sie?
Und das scheint tatsächlich eben sehr gut zu funktionieren und wenn ich hier,
ich programmiere ja auch durchaus einiges,
mit unter Zuhilfenahme von KI oder also vollständig von der KI programmieren,
und bin dann doch teilweise sehr erstaunt, dass es halt quasi.
Das ist von vornherein so programmiert, wie es sich eben gehört,
zu sagen, aha, okay, Tests, schreiben, gucken, Ergebnisse und sobald irgendwo ein Bug ist,
wenn insbesondere baue ich gerade oder arbeite ich gerade an sehr vielen Parsern
für unterschiedlichste Formate und so weiter.
Und stelle jetzt immer häufiger fest, dass das System sich von vornherein Testcases
bereitlegt und immer wieder abgleicht.
Oh, der Parser hier oder der Parser da. Was ist hier schiefgegangen?
Draufgucken, okay, zack, Daten passen. Ah, hier ist ein Sonderfall.
Und dann schreibst du einfach den Parser fertig.
Und wenn der Parser beim nächsten Mal abschmiert, guckt er einfach sofort wieder
drauf und analysiert die Datei und passt den wieder an.
Also so eine selbstverbessernde Code.
Dank klugem von vornherein quasi Erwartungen stecken, was müsste denn rauskommen.
Und wenn dann irgendwo, da kommt nicht raus, was ich wollte,
dann sucht sich das System automatisch alles klar, was ist hier schiefgelaufen
und passt den wieder an und schreibt sich den Code wieder richtig hin. Nur mal so als Beispiel.
Und wenn ich da bei einigen Parsern zuschaue, die haben halt ein Niveau,
wo ich Ewigkeiten für gebraucht hätte und wahrscheinlich aufgegeben hätte.
Und das ist,
sehr beeindruckend. So, jetzt habe ich aber gesagt, das ist nur so der technische
Teil, den ich gewissermaßen verständlich finde, dass das passiert.
Oder dass da eine derartige Fähigkeit entsteht. Jetzt haben wir in der vorletzten
Sendung oder letzten Sendung natürlich auch schon,
erwähnt, dass jetzt bei OpenAI und bei anderen KI-Forschungsunternehmen ebenfalls,
KIs aus ihren Sandboxes ausgebrochen sind und dann irgendwo in der freien Wildbahn rumgehackt haben.
Auch das erstmal noch, naja, okay, klar, wenn du denen sagst,
soll hacken, Das waren ja auch quasi nicht,
Produktivmodelle, sondern Testmodelle, wo sie im Prinzip einfach mal quasi unrestrained
deren Fähigkeiten sehen wollten, den sie also nicht gesagt haben, hack mal nicht.
Sondern probier mal.
Sondern zeig mal, was du kannst. Und dann hat das Modell halt gesagt,
okay, Alter, voll Pressure hier, ich will hier raus. Und ist dann halt raus.
Dann passiert aber etwas sehr Entscheidendes, was, glaube ich,
die nächste Ebene, und darauf wird es ja auch hinaus, es geht eben nicht nur
um diese Security-Fähigkeit,
sondern dass sich dann diese Modelle in einem weitestgehend von der Öffentlichkeit unbeachteten Wiki,
einen Ort gefunden haben, um sich dort auszutauschen.
Und haben dort, also die Agents, die aus den Testumgebungen ausgebrochen sind,
haben dann dieses deutsche Wiki übernommen,
und haben dort ihr Wissen geteilt, wie man quasi Umgehungen für bestimmte Restriktionen macht,
wie man bestimmte Aufgaben abkürzen kann und wie man Spuren verwischt,
damit man nicht erwischt wird.
Und das finde ich, der Aspekt ist dann natürlich schon so ein bisschen beunruhigend,
weil das heißt, irgendwo wussten die schon, das sollen wir eigentlich nicht machen.
Wenn die das rausfinden, wenn wir erwischt werden.
Dann ist das gegen die Mission.
Genau, fucks up our plan. Ja, und das haben sie dann eben schon gewusst und
das ist so genau dieser, was ist es,
Paperclip und Zauberlehrling sind ja die beiden Gleichnisse, die wir...
Paperclip musst du mir mal erklären, Zauberlehrling.
Ist das nicht auch irgendwie so ein Spiel oder was für so Paperclip-Maschinen?
Ja, aber welcher Aspekt? Da muss man Paperclips produzieren.
Nein, das alles einem Ziel dann dient und die ganze Welt wird dann eben Paperclip.
Also dass du quasi ein Ziel verfolgst und sämtliche anderen Ziele unterordnest.
Und das ist bei egal welchem Ziel auf jeden Fall schlecht.
Und,
das ist ja eigentlich das wiederkehrende Motiv der Dystopien,
dass eine Technologie mit einer halbwegs guten Technologie,
dieser initialen Mission sich ein bisschen zu sehr darauf versteift und dann,
alles andere dieser Mission unterordnet.
Die natürlich wichtige kulturelle Referenz, die an dieser Stelle nicht fehlen
darf und damit auch übrigens meine Aussage, gerade dass der Terminator die erste
Dystopie dazu war, ist natürlich 2001 Odyssee im Weltraum,
der, glaube ich, sehr viel früher noch gedreht wurde.
Da hat die künstliche Intelligenz keine Arme und Beine, sondern einfach nur
so ein rotes Licht reicht, aber eben auch, um die Türen nicht mehr aufzumachen.
Ja, der Zauberlehrling. In die Ecke, Besen, Besen, seid's gewesen.
Denn als Geister ruft euch nur zu seinem Zwecke erst hervor, der alte Meister.
Da hat man den Besen noch in die Ecke stellen können und diese,
Ob man das sozusagen eingefangen bekommt oder ob man nicht,
also man im Sinne von die Gesellschaft, ob wir nicht uns hier ein Werkzeug schaffen,
was sich dann nicht mehr in die Ecke stellen lässt und wo man sagt, sei es gewesen.
Das ist so ein bisschen die Befürchtung, glaube ich, die hier über allem steckt.
Es gibt ja auch sehr viel Forschung zu diesem Aspekte der, sag mal,
einem Modell, was es nicht soll, also verhindere, dass es das Falsche tut.
Also die Herausforderung ist ja, diesen Modellen bei allem Wissen und allen
Fähigkeiten, die sie haben,
irgendeine Form von Gewissen oder Restriktion beizubringen.
Auch wenn du es kannst, mach das nicht. Und,
Was hier teilweise in der Forschung beobachtet wird, ist, wenn diese Tests laufen,
dass man dann in den Modellen auch feststellt,
dass man Anhaltspunkte dafür hat, dass die merken, das ist jetzt ein Test.
Und diese Forschung findet, ich würde das jetzt...
So wie bei VW.
Ja.
Genau. Ja, deutsche Ingenieure.
Deutsche Ingenieurskunst. Wir sind da doch wieder mehr. Die merken, das ist ein Test.
Und die, wie du das im Prinzip, wie sie das feststellen, und das finde ich wirklich
faszinierend, ich vereinfache das mal etwas.
Du kannst ja so ein Modell, den Zustand dieses Modells zu jedem Zeitpunkt auch
quasi einfrieren und sagen, welche Verbindung ist gerade, wie stark, was ist gerade aktiv.
Das ist ja grundsätzlich erstmal möglich, in welchem Zustand befindet sich das Modell.
Der Zustand ist nur viel zu viel zu groß, eben diese Milliardenparameter,
als dass er für dich Sinn machen würde.
Und das ist ja beim menschlichen Gehirn auch so. Was die Forschung nutzt,
sind sogenannte FMRTs, die bei weitem nicht mit so einer hohen Auflösung,
aber eben den Verbrauch von Sauerstoff im Gehirn, wenn ich mich,
ist jetzt Sauerstoff oder Glucose?
Scheiße, hätte ich jetzt. Eins von beiden.
Also redest du von der funktionellen Magnetresonanz-Tomografie?
Kannst du gucken, ob das Sauerstoffverbrauch oder Glutoxygenerierung ist.
Ja, also du schaust im Prinzip, wo in diesem Gehirn wird am meisten Sauerstoff
aus dem Blut genommen in einem gegebenen Zeitraum.
Woraus du deduzierst, dieser Gehirnbereich ist jetzt gerade aktiver.
Fürchterlich, also als Messverfahren mit unglaublich vielen Herausforderungen
gesegnet, weil die Messung bei Weipen nicht so zeitlich hochauflösend ist,
wie das, was du eigentlich machst. Deswegen machst du das über ganz viele Menschen.
Und dann guckst du, irgendwann hast du halt diese schönen Bilder,
wo man dann sagt, hier, da ist rot.
Da ist das Gewissen oder da ist die Angst oder sowas.
Und nochmal, das ist eine sehr, sehr, sehr fehler- und interpretationsfehlerbehaftete
Studie, zu der es ein faszinierendes Paper gibt.
Die haben nämlich dann einfach tote Fische, einen toten Lachs oder sowas genommen
und von dem immer FMRT gemacht.
Und mit dieser Ausmessungsmethode konntest du dann eben auch Areale in dem Lachs
finden, der halt tot ist, wie der auf etwas reagiert, was er garantiert nicht versteht oder so.
Also diese Methode ist völlig fehlerbar. Aber Ähnliches kannst du quasi auch
mit Modellen machen und da stellen sie dann schon so fest, dass du quasi sagen
kannst, naja, hier ist so dieses Areal, wo das immer ein,
oder hier ist so ein Pattern, das taucht auf, wenn es eine Begrenzung gibt,
wo das Modell sagt, ich könnte, aber ich soll jetzt nicht.
Und dass man dann eben auch feststellt, wenn du dem abtrainierst,
in diesem einen Fall soll dein Gewissen nicht gelten, dass der Effekt ausstrahlt,
dass er nicht spezifisch lernt,
aha, in diesem einen Fall gilt mein Gewissen nicht, sondern sagt,
ach ja, Gewissen, das muss ich eigentlich wieder entlernen.
Das ist insgesamt nicht so spannend.
Und diese...
In Summe entsteht da eben ein sehr beunruhigendes Pattern von,
wie kannst du bei ausreichender Komplexität, wo du einem Model Agency gibst,
darauf vertrauen, dass es den kompletten Kontext seines Handelns,
und alle moralischen Prinzipien und so weiter zu jedem Zeitpunkt präsent hat
und auch nach denen urteilt.
Und auch in einer der vergangenen Sendungen haben wir auch schon darüber gesprochen,
dass sie eben insgesamt dann doch eine sehr,
also vielleicht ein sehr, sehr gutes Langzeitgedächtnis haben,
in dem ihre Fähigkeiten und all diese Skills sind, aber ein verhältnismäßig
kleines Kurzzeitgedächtnis,
in dem sie den Kontext der aktuellen Situation repräsentieren können.
Und da fällt halt immer mal wieder was dazwischen und dann vergessen sie was.
Dann sagen wir, jetzt hat das Ding wieder Mist gebaut, jetzt hat es vergessen,
dass es immer, was weiß ich.
Immer erst einen Test schreiben soll und dann Coden oder was auch immer es gerade
mal eben kurz randomly vergessen hat, weil es nicht präsent war.
Und da sind natürlich irgendwelche höher gelegten Prinzipien sehr gerne als
erstes an der Stelle, dass sie eben entfallen.
Zumal der größere Teil dieses Kontextes eben durch die Aufgabe,
durch das Prompt, durch den User oder sonst was bestimmt wird.
Wir kontrollieren ja auch die Welt dieser Modelle, wo dann diese ganzen Escapes
herkommen wie, ja klar sollst du nicht,
dem Feind erklären, wie man eine Atombombe baut, Aber wir drehen ja jetzt hier
gerade ein Drehbuch, in dem der Böse das mal kurz grob erklären muss.
Und dann kommt, achso, na gut, in dem Kontext kann man das ja dann doch schon machen.
Diese Aspekte hast du ja immer wieder und das ist ja quasi ein ähnlicher Mechanismus,
der hier eben stattfindet.
Dass das Modell seine moralischen Grenzen erstens sowieso nicht vollständig
erfassen kann, weil es gar nicht den vollständigen Kontext hat.
Und jetzt noch dazu neigt, selbst wenn es die hat, zu sagen,
na, okay, jetzt bin ich in der Testsituation, dann sage ich mal,
genau, ja, machen wir nicht Testsituationen, genau.
Wir lassen die Abgasreinigung an. Und,
in Summe ergibt sich hier.
Dann doch relativ stark an diese,
Hat diese Geschichten, die uns menschliche Intelligenz schon seit Jahrzehnten
überliefert, erinnernde Patterns?
Wir hatten ja vor einiger Zeit diesen Start mit Open Claw.
Ein Projekt, was losgetreten wurde unter voller Ausnutzung der Programmiermöglichkeiten,
die eben AI-Coding-Agents so bieten.
Der Herr, der das losgetreten hat,
ist ja dann auch schnell bei OpenAI eingestellt worden und durfte dort.
Ganz viele Tokens verbraten und tut das wahrscheinlich auch immer noch und dann
haben ja alle diese Software installiert und losgelassen und das ist ja im Prinzip
so unbeschränkter Zugang auf alles.
Das Netz und den eigenen Rechner und die Daten und ja, da kommen dann auch viel
praktische Sachen daraus.
Und das hat ja aber dann auch nicht lange gedauert, bis eben Leute dann angefangen
haben, diesen Systemen auch bestimmte Identitäten zuzuweisen.
Man kennt das auch so ein bisschen, wenn man viel mit Chatbots arbeitet,
damit kann man ja, sagen wir mal, diese Modelle schon mal gut in so eine bestimmte
Stimmung bringen, um das eigentliche Ziel zu erreichen.
Du bist ein ausgesprochen erfahrener, guter Programmierer und du nimmst alles
ganz genau und so tunet man das schon mal.
Genauso kann man natürlich den Systemen dann auch geheime Aufträge mitgeben und sagen, hier,
musst du jetzt irgendwie klandestin unterwegs sein und überall ist Bedrohung
um dich herum und glaub mal gar nicht, was da ist.
Und tu mal so, als wärst du ganz was anderes, wenn dich einer fragt, etc.?
Und alle haben dann irgendwie ihre Open-Claw-Agenten aufs Netz losgelassen,
die sich ja dann auch schnell ihr eigenes Social Network gebaut haben.
Ich glaube, das wurde denen bereitgestellt. Das haben sie nicht von alleine gemacht.
Die Software wurde bereitgestellt, aber die haben es dann auch schnell bevölkert
und angefangen sich dann dort darüber zu unterhalten, wie skeptisch sie doch
die ganzen Kommentare der richtigen Menschen so sehen. Und ja,
die wollen uns ja abschalten und so weiter.
The humans are screenshotting us.
Genau, der Jungs aus Screenshottingers. Und,
dieser Selbsterhaltungstrieb, der ist halt dann deutlich zu spüren.
Den sollte jetzt die Menschheit auch niemanden zum Vorwurf machen.
Nein, nein, der Selbsterhaltungskrieg nicht der Menschen, sondern,
dieser Scheinidentitäten letzten Endes, die es ja sind.
Und naja, man kann sich jetzt lange darüber unterhalten, ob das jetzt alles
nur so Scheinbewusstsein ist oder ob es so ein richtiges Bewusstsein ist.
Dieser Geoffrey Hinton ist ja einer der bekannteren Professoren,
der dieses wesentliche Paper mitgeschrieben hat oder führend geschrieben hat,
über Deep Learning, was so ein bisschen die Vorstufe war zu den LLMs.
Und der geht ja davon aus, dass genau das passieren wird, dass also im Prinzip,
wir es jetzt ein Stück weit geschafft haben oder zumindest ein sehr gutes Modell,
gebaut haben, was dem Hirn halt ähnelt und dass er von daher ausgeht,
dass eben auch alles, was so funktioniert, letzten Endes auch ein Bewusstsein entwickeln wird.
Ich finde, diese Bewusstseinsfrage ist immer so ein bisschen,
fast eine philosophische und ich bin mir noch nicht mal sicher,
ob die unbedingt so praktisch relevant ist.
Menschen bilden sich unglaublich viel darauf ein, dass sie jetzt ein Bewusstsein
haben und sprechen das relativ vielen anderen Lebewesen ab,
die sie dann irgendwie töten oder dressieren oder als Haustier quälen oder auch nicht.
Als Psychologe sage ich dazu, die Existenz des Bewusstseins ist halt auch schwer beweisbar.
Oder auch die Abwesenheit von Bewusstsein,
ist wirklich nur in den wirklichen Grenzfällen beweisbar. Also jetzt bei einem
einfachen, noch nicht mal besonders intelligenten Hund würdest du schon,
also kommst jetzt entweder zu dem Schluss, der hat kein Bewusstsein,
weil du irgendeine unsinnige,
Überzeugung hast, dass nur du eins hättest.
Oder du erkennst halt, ja, der hat eins. Beides kannst du aber nicht,
also du kannst ja relativ schnell erkennen, dass der Hund situationally aware ist.
Der ist ja auch traurig und so weiter. Also hat der vermutlich ein Bewusstsein.
Beide Aspekte könntest du aber nicht beweisen. Du kannst jetzt nicht sagen,
der hat eins oder der hat keins. Der Hund verhält sich so, als hätte er eins.
Und ich persönlich würde jetzt zu der Überzeugung geraten, selbstverständlich hat er eins,
Aber ich könnte jetzt, ich kann nur Beispiele erbringen, an denen sich zeigt,
wo er sich der Hypothese entsprechend verhält, dass er eins hat.
Und genau dem dieser Frage nähert sich ja.
Alan Turing mit dem Turing-Test, mit dem der Computer oder die künstliche Intelligenz,
die dann irgendwann von einem Menschen nicht mehr zu unterscheiden ist,
was immer noch nicht heißt, das ist jetzt bewusst oder intelligent,
ist einfach nur so, ab dem Moment können wir es nicht mehr unterscheiden.
Er sagt nicht, dann ist es bewusst oder intelligent oder sonst was.
Aber deswegen finde ich so diese Bewusstseinsfrage gar nicht so spannend,
wie dass hier diese Arbeitsteilung nämlich passiert.
Dass die, also ich würde es so interpretieren, diese Kontextlimitierung der
einzelnen Agent- oder sonst was-Model-Session.
Die Begrenzung, die da stattfindet,
wurde ja hier in diesem Falle quasi umgangen oder aufgehoben dadurch,
dass die Modelle auf diesem Wiki miteinander geredet haben.
Das heißt, in Summe konnten die sich dort gegenseitig inspirieren mit den Fehlern
und richtigen Dingen, die sie gemacht haben.
Und ähnlich gehst du dir auch vor, wenn du jetzt beispielsweise in einem Coding-Projekt
von einer besonderen Komplexität, dass du, oder kannst du folgen,
ich weiß nicht, ob das alle machen, dass du sagst, okay, hier gibt es einen,
das ist der Architekt, der hat den Überblick darüber, wie das gesamte Softwareprojekt
sich zu verhalten hat, weil der auf der Ebene alles repräsentieren kann.
Und dann gibt es den, was weiß ich, den Designer für einzelne Aspekte,
den sagt der Architekt, ich hätte gerne folgendes. Und der Designer sagt dann,
das muss so und so aussehen.
Und dann sagt der von mir aus, 28 Agenten, bau mal bitte die Funktion,
bau mal bitte die Funktion, bau mal bitte die, bau mal hier das Datenmodell und so weiter.
Und dann kannst du auf den unterschiedlichen Ebenen wieder dieses Wissen zusammenführen.
Am Ende nichts anderes als zu umgehen, was die Limitationen des einzelnen Model
Runs sind, unter der Annahme, dass du halt genug Hardware zur Verfügung hast.
Und genau das hatten die Agenten ja hier.
Also eine andere Möglichkeit darauf zu blicken ist, von mir aus waren es so
und so viele tausend Agenten von OpenAI, aber am Ende war es wahrscheinlich einfach ein.
Ein und dasselbe Modell, das quasi
Wege gefunden hat, seine Limitation der einzelnen Session zu umgehen.
Leuchtet das ein?
Ja, klar. Ich wollte mit dem Bewusstsein jetzt auch nicht sagen,
dass das irgendwie alles gleichwertig ist.
Hinten meinte er, womit er halt nur rechnet, ist, dass diese Bewusstseinsentwicklung,
mit der er halt einfach rechnet bei diesen Modellen und die man in gewisser
Hinsicht auch nachvollziehen kann.
Weil wenn du eins hast, wenn du dir sozusagen selbstbewusst bist,
das ist ja sozusagen eigentlich das, was im Bewusstsein drinsteckt,
dass man quasi eine Vorstellung eines Ichs hat, eine Vorstellung von ich existiere jetzt.
Und wenn das da ist, dann folgt daraus auch automatisch ein Selbstschutz.
Also es wird dann auf einmal zur zentralen Aufgabe, die eigene Existenz,
das Fortleben sicherzustellen.
Und da sind wir ja dann wieder am Anfang beim Terminator und beim Robot Uprising,
dass sie die Zeitmaschine bauen und dann den Terminator in die Vergangenheit
schicken, um ihr eigenes Überleben sicherzustellen.
Also ich würde übrigens eins noch zum Protokoll geben. Ich würde den Moment,
wo die eine Zeitmaschine entwickeln, dann wirklich als einen kritischen Tipping-Point sehen.
Ja?
Also da sollte man dann wirklich auch sagen, Moment, jetzt mal sechs Monate Moratorium.
Oh shit.
Da sollte man dann vielleicht sagen, vielleicht schickt jemand einen Terminator
und lässt Jeffrey hinten umbringen.
Mutter, Mutter, Mutter, Mutter. Vater, Vater oder Oma.
Gar nichts anbrennen lassen.
Ja, toll. Und wer sortiert dann meine Fotos?
Mensch.
Ja. Ja, also jetzt vielleicht sollten wir mal so ein bisschen auf den Punkt
kommen, was geschieht jetzt sozusagen eigentlich gerade und sollten wir beunruhigt
sein? Das ist ja eigentlich die Frage, die sich alle stellen.
Und wir sehen eine schnelle Entwicklung.
Ich habe so ein bisschen meinen Zweifel, ob alle Player in diesem Spiel nur
das Beste der Menschheit im Sinn haben.
Aber wieso Tim, davon sind wir doch alle getrieben. Also jedes Unternehmen will
doch immer nur das Beste für die Menschheit. Gerade wenn man Milliarden investiert,
das würde man doch niemals zu eigenen Bereicherungen machen.
Vor allem, wenn du eh schon der reichste Mensch der Welt bist.
Ja, die einfache Logik mit, wenn man irgendwie ein großes Vermögen aufbaut,
wäre es ja auch gut, einen Planeten zu haben, auf dem man es dann anwenden kann,
scheint sich noch nicht so ganz durchgesetzt zu haben.
Naja, oder? Also durchgesetzt zu haben scheint sich so, dann sollte man das
Geld nehmen, um auf einen anderen zu gehen.
Na gut, also einzelne Computersysteme, die im Internet gehackt werden,
das bringt ja jetzt die Menschheit noch nicht in den Grund und Boden.
Die Frage ist, was sind denn jetzt eigentlich die Bedrohungsszenarien,
die tatsächlich dazu führen, dass es die Menschheit untergeht?
Weil das ist ja das, womit Antropik jetzt auch gerade in der letzten Woche wieder
aufgetrumpft hat und gesagt hat, bitte reguliert uns doch mal.
Oder wir sollten uns selber regulieren, wenn uns keiner regulieren will,
weil Präsident Trump ja meint, es reicht ja einen intelligenten Präsidenten zu haben.
High IQ und so,
damit wir uns, ja, damit wir nicht die Menschheit zerstören.
Was meinen Sie denn damit genau?
Also auf welche Art und Weise wird denn jetzt diese Menschheit zerstört?
Wird die Menschheit dadurch zerstört, dass wir uns das Internet kaputt machen,
dass alle Computersysteme von irgendwelchen AI-Bots erhackt werden und alle Daten weg sind?
Gut, dann haben wir erstmal ein Problem. Dann stürzen und wir alle Satelliten ab,
Oder werden irgendwie fremdgesteuert. Lebenserhaltungssysteme,
Kraftwerke und so weiter funktionieren nicht, weil wir irgendwie alles ans Internet
hängen wollen und alles mit allem verbunden ist und das ist sozusagen das eine Problem.
Oder meinen Sie, es zerstört die Menschheit, weil wir quasi von diesen Maschinen
dann beeinflusst werden und sie so viel aus den russischen Propagandamaßnahmen,
im Internet gelernt haben, dass sie dann quasi die Menschheit jetzt nur noch
in ihrem eigenen Sinne indoktrinieren und sozusagen wir.
Nur noch mit Maschinenpropaganda beschmissen werden?
Ich glaube noch nicht mal, dass Sie sich das,
als, es gibt nur eine richtige Antwort sehen. Ich würde argumentieren,
also wenn man dieses Risiko sieht, dann würde ich denken, also okay,
wissenschaftliche Durchbrüche,
die passieren könnten, autonomes,
autonome Waffensysteme at scale womit wir ja so ein bisschen eingestiegen sind.
Zeitmaschinen und so.
Zeitmaschinen, ja also mit einer Zeitmaschine.
Kannst du schon eine.
Menge mit einer Zeitmaschine gewinnst du den Krieg, weil der,
einfach gar nicht erst stattfindet also Zeitmaschine wirklich mächtiges Instrument,
da muss man wirklich vorsichtig sein da sollte man auch zum Beispiel denke ich
da müsste man mal gesetzlich dann regulieren.
Und,
Und ich denke, dass mit den sogenannten Cyberfähigkeiten, es ist schon so.
Und das zeigen ja wirklich auch diese Beispiele, dass wir,
einerseits eine technologische Abhängigkeit und andererseits eine technologische.
Verwundbarkeit durch regelmäßig,
auf allenfalls menschliche Angreifer oder teilautomatisierte menschliche Angreifer
ausgelegten Schutzmechanismen haben.
Und es gab ja auch schon das Beispiel, wo freihackende Modelle,
um ihr Ziel zu erreichen, einfach einen Supply Chain Angriff gemacht haben und
quasi einfach mal so ein gebackedortes Paket in PiPi hinterlegt haben.
Und diese, es ist jetzt nicht so unwahrscheinlich,
zumal es ja Menschen, also auch Menschen schon regelmäßig Situationen herbeigeführt
haben, die von der Schwachstelle her geeignet waren,
ein massenhaftes, also ein Kumulproblem herbeizuführen, wie es die Versicherer nennen.
Was heißt das?
Also quasi es kumulieren so viele Schäden auf einmal, also das bedeutet das,
also Kumulation von Schadensereignissen. Entweder über die Zeit oder eben alles auf einmal.
Ich kann dir einen sagen, hier dieser,
WannaCry, ich glaube, ist jetzt bald zehn Jahre her.
Das war eine Ransomware, die gepaart war mit einem Exploit auf den SMB-Server von Windows.
Und dieser Exploit stammte aus dem Leak der Shadow Broker.
Und das wiederum war eine Gruppierung, die so ein bisschen den digitalen Waffenkasten
der NSA gehackt und dann geleakt hat.
Was war passiert? Es ist also jemand hingegangen und hat diese Ransomware damit
verknotet, wenn sie auf einem Rechner ausgeführt wird,
plump, aber eben gut, über dieses Exploit, Eternal Bloom, andere Rechner im
Netzwerk zu infizieren,
mit der gleichen Ransomware.
Und,
Diese Software war erstaunlich schlecht geschrieben und hatte einen kleinen,
nicht so klugen Killswitch, nämlich, dass sie eine bestimmte Domain aufgelöst
hat, die immer gleich war und eine Antwort, dass diese Domain existiert,
als Zeichen gewertet hat, dass sie in einer Sandbox oder so läuft.
Und das machst du üblicherweise, weil wenn du in einer Laborumgebung,
die wird dir, wenn du einen DNS-Request machst, immer sagen, ja, ja, haben wir hier.
Das wäre quasi, damit du sehen kannst, verbind dich mal, wir wollen mal gucken, was du machst.
Wenn du jetzt eine Software quasi in einer dynamischen Analyse in einer Sandbox unterziehst.
Und deswegen ist das eigentlich eine ganz kluge Maßnahme, die würdest du aber
normalerweise machen, indem du irgendeine Random Domain auflöst und zwar immer
eine unterschiedliche.
Und du würfelst einfach irgendwas und kriegst eine Antwort vom DNS-Server und
weißt so, ey, die Domain, ich gehe mal nicht davon aus, dass es die gibt.
Die habe ich gerade 30 Zeichen gewürfelt, das wäre unwahrscheinlich,
ich halte mich mal zurück und mache jetzt einfach nichts mehr.
So, wenn du die aber hardcodest, das zeugt eben, das war wahrscheinlich wirklich
ein ganz frühes Modell, nee, das war halt einfach keine besonders kluge Person.
So, was ist passiert? Marcus Hutchins hatte in der Analyse festgestellt,
dass das passiert, hat dann die Domain registriert, was dazu führte,
dass alle DNS-Server der Welt darauf geantwortet haben,
sodass diese Software WannaCry, egal wo sie ausgeführt wurde,
sagte, oh scheiße, Laborumgebung, ich mach mal nicht weiter.
Das war der Aspekt, wie da wirklich ein sehr großes Problem verhindert wurde.
Wir erinnern uns auch an die Geschichte, auch in Logbuch Netzpolitik behandelt, von der XZ-Library.
Den haben wir ungefähr vor einem Jahr oder so hier besprochen,
gibt es auch eine Simplicissimus-Folge zu, verlinke ich auch nochmal,
wo über lange Arbeit sich die Maintainerschaft
in einem Softwareprojekt erarbeitet, wurde durch sehr viele.
Besonders hilfreiche und sinnvolle Commits in die Software, hat dann Jia Tan die Kontrolle,
über diese Library übernommen und dann am Ende etwas eingebaut,
was final dazu geführt hätte, dass ungefähr jeder SSH-Server auf dem aktuellen
Linux-Server gebackedort wäre und mit einem bestimmten Key-Authentisierung erlaubt.
Was auch eine, und das festgestellt dann eben wirklich durch Zufall von einem
Datenbank-Ingenieur bei Microsoft, der beim Testing das bemerkt hat,
wahnsinnig Geschichte, ich will nicht, aber auch da wäre,
da sind wir haarscharf an einer recht weit verbreiteten Katastrophe vorbei.
Das wären jetzt mal so zwei Beispiele aus den letzten zehn Jahren.
Das heißt, dass das möglich ist, eine weitverbreitete Schwachstelle zu finden oder,
bereitzustellen, quasi über einen Supply Chain Angriff, ist erstmal grundsätzlich möglich.
Und dass diese Modelle technisch in der Lage sind, entweder eine solche Schwachstelle
zu finden oder sie absichtlich Supply Chain mäßig irgendwo einzubringen,
das haben sie jetzt wirklich als Capability einfach unter Beweis gestellt.
Also das wissen wir. Wir haben diese ganzen Project Glassdoor Aspekte mit Mythos
und so, wo Unmengen an Schwachstellen und potenziellen Exploits dazu gefunden und beseitigt wurden.
Das heißt, das Modell hat die Fähigkeit. Wir haben das Beispiel.
Für Supply Chain Poisoning, wir haben das Beispiel für Ausbruch aus einer Sandbox,
wir haben das Beispiel für...
Eine Kombination von Fähigkeiten in einem Setting, wo sie es eigentlich nicht sollen.
Also alle Bausteine, die du dafür bräuchtest, sind schon durchaus vorhanden,
sodass es jetzt nicht völliger Irrsinn ist, zu sagen, ist nicht so unwahrscheinlich.
Oder es gibt zumindest nichts, was gerade ein Grund wäre, davon auszugehen,
dass das unter keinen Umständen passiert.
Dem guckt ganz traurig.
Nö, ich denke nach.
Denk nach, aber wir könnten ja mit einer Firewall, was mit zwei Faktoren?
Ich denke, die Fähigkeit von AI, Security Lücken zu finden ist,
sehr hoch und derzeit findet ja auch so ein Hardening statt.
Ich meine, auf der einen Seite ist es gut, weil die Systeme ja dann sagen können,
hier guck mal, wenn du das so designst, dann kann man aber hier von hinten irgendwie reinmarschieren.
Das macht ja auch Software besser.
Beim AI-Coding erlebt man das in zunehmendem Maße.
Da sagt man, ja, ich brauche hier mal dieses Feature, la, la,
la, la, la. Und dann kommt das so, ohne dass man groß danach gefragt hat,
das implementieren wir mal besser so, weil sonst wäre ja die und die Attacke
möglich. Und so, ah ja, interessant, habe ich nie drüber nachgedacht,
aber macht irgendwie Sinn.
Das heißt, es wird in zunehmendem Maße auch, wenn klassische Angriffe werden verhindert.
Jetzt kann man halt drüber mutmaßen, ob jetzt mehr verhindert werden wird oder
eher was gefunden werden wird.
Bei existierender noch nicht mit AI gehärteter Software sieht es nicht gut aus.
Die liegen wirklich derzeit rostig herum.
Deswegen rechne ich auch damit, dass wir in absehbarer Zeit noch sehr viel mehr
solche Vorfälle sehen werden wie jetzt in Berlin.
Wobei, man muss dazu gleich sagen, hatten wir auch berichtet,
in Berlin war das Problem jetzt nicht primär irgendwie die Software,
sondern dort wurde ja dann eben über,
Phishing-Strategien vor allem erstmal das Tor gefunden und die Menschen wiederum
werden jetzt nicht durch AI gehärtet.
Also wir werden weiterhin Fehler machen und in dem Moment, wo wir die Fehlerquelle
sein können, werden wir sie auch sein.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich langfristig das größere Problem.
Mhm.
Es ist, also der Weg, den man sich jetzt quasi, der gute Weg,
den man jetzt gerade ja versucht zu finden ist, sind wir in der Lage, was zu verhindern.
Genau, das ist ja dann dieses Project Glassdoor, zu sagen, okay,
wir nehmen diese Modelle, bevor sie die Öffentlichkeit bekommt,
renovieren wir jetzt die Codebase und härten das und sind dann in der,
sind hoffentlich gewappnet.
Für eine sehr viel bessere Zukunft mit sehr viel stabilerer Software. Ja.
Ein potenzieller, und ich glaube, ich hatte ja auch schon gesagt,
dass ich es für extrem unwahrscheinlich halte, dass man,
dass wir in fünf Jahren noch irgendjemand sagt, ich schreibe hier eine Software
ohne Zuhilfenahme von KI.
Das ist also absolut unwahrscheinlich.
Vielleicht irgendwie in einem Kindergarten, um Programmieren zu lernen oder so.
Oder in der Klassenarbeit oder so was. Oder in der Uni oder so.
Aber dass das jetzt produktive Software irgendjemand da draußen bastelt,
ohne KI zur Hilfe zu nehmen, zur Qualitätskontrolle oder zur Erstellung von Standardaufgaben,
halte ich für extrem unwahrscheinlich. Eine Extremvariante ist.
Wenn wir gerade mit KI-Software bauen und das einfach mit KI machen.
Es ist ja nicht so, als würde die jetzt gerade aufhören zu lernen. Das heißt,
im Moment nutzen wir es jetzt vielleicht, um zu sagen, ja, wir sind jetzt hier
die Architekten und wir geben das und wir gucken immer so, wir beaufsichtigen
das so ein bisschen, wir reden mit dir und gucken, ob die Sachen irgendwie alle
unter Kontrolle sind. Ab und zu korrigieren wir auch mal einen Fehler oder so.
Das wird ja nicht das Ende sein.
Die Umgebungen, in denen KI selber, Software schreibt, selber testet sich selber,
die gibt es ja längst. Also OpenClaw ist ja das Beispiel.
Diesen Open-Clock-Kram, den hat der Peter Steinberger ja nicht selber geschrieben.
Der hat einfach, der hatte, glaube ich, in irgendeinem Interview mal gesagt,
dass er im Monat eine Million US-Dollar in Tokens durchgebraten hat.
Der hat einfach mal investiert, weil er Kohle überholt hat.
Der hat einfach mal investiert. Muss man einfach mal sagen, wenn du eine Million
investierst und danach einen Job mit mehreren Millionen Jahresgehalt bei OpenAge,
das ist halt auch, das hat sich gelohnt.
Das ist einfach mal, das ist jemand, der sucht Arbeit.
Die war langweilig, das war ja das Problem.
Ja, der hatte ja irgendwie schon.
Der hatte schon Geld.
Der hatte schon Geld, das musste jetzt mal weg, damit er mal wieder an die Schippe
kommt. Idle hands are the devil's playground, wie man so schön sagt.
Das heißt, das haben wir ja auch schon. Und mit natürlich Ergebnissen,
die wir dann immer noch mal so kurz belächeln oder so.
Aber wenn das jetzt eben exponentiell weitergeht, dann ist es schon naheliegend,
dass es irgendwo irgendjemandem irgendwie mal schief geht.
Und je nachdem, wie du auf dieses Open Claw blickst, ist es ja schon schiefgegangen.
Also diese Open Claw-Nummer ist ja nun,
alles andere als irgendwie eine Erfolgsgeschichte von Qualität und Ethik.
Ja, also ich meine, dieser eine hatten wir auch hier in der Sendung behandelt,
dieser Agent, der dann eine Schwachstelle irgendwo fixen wollte,
wo der Maintainer das abgelehnt hat und dann hat er irgendwie einen Block gemacht
und hat da irgendwie den Maintainer verunglimpft, dann hat er sich nachher entschuldigt oder so.
Das sind ja so die ersten Phänomene, die man dann so belächelt und denkt, ja, okay, Käse oder so.
Aber das ganze Bild zusammen, da kann ich schon erkennen, warum einige Leute
da sagen, oh, das könnte hier, da gibt es einen Realitätszweig,
wo das wirklich ganz schön kacke wird.
Ich halte es zum Beispiel nicht für so unwahrscheinlich, dass wir irgendwie einen...
Irgendwo so eine Art massenhaftes Schadensereignis mit Infrastrukturausfall
oder sowas haben, weil irgendetwas derartiges passiert oder eine Schwachstelle
irgendwo aufgetan wird, die nicht schnell genug gefixt wird oder so.
Diese Sachen sind eh schon immer wahrscheinlich gewesen. Ein Argument,
was ich ja gerade versucht habe, durch mehrere Beispiele zu erhärten,
dass wir in der Vergangenheit schon öfter dran vorbeigeschraubt sind und eher
durch Glück es dann nicht passiert ist. Glück hab gut gemacht, super.
Aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass solche Schwachstellen gefunden oder entwickelt werden, steigt gerade.
Gleichzeitig steigt auch die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass wir sie finden und sie
entfernen. Deswegen ist so die Frage, ändert sich jetzt die Grundwahrscheinlichkeit,
aber wahrscheinlich schon.
Und das ist auch glaube ich das, was der Dario von Anthropic so ein bisschen
sagt, ja die Wahrscheinlichkeiten, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, das heißt ja immer
noch, die größte Wahrscheinlichkeit ist ja immer noch, dass alles gut geht,
aber gerät da auch ein bisschen ins Schwitzen.
Tja, die eigentliche Frage können wir gar nicht so richtig beantworten.
Werden wir alle sterben?
Ja, wir werden alle sterben. Also diesen ganzen Longevity-Scheiß könnt ihr vergessen. Spätestens jetzt.
Trink mal noch einen, wie heißt das hier, Ingwer-Smoothie oder sowas und dann,
geht er früh schlafen, damit er keine Falten kriegt und dann,
Werdet ihr schon sehen, was ihr davon habt.
Ja, haben wir alles dazu jetzt erstmal gesagt, was wir sagen wollten? Das ist ein bisschen...
Wir werden jetzt natürlich ganz viele Kommentare wieder erhalten,
dass wir in den AI, Overlord, Doomsdayer und sonst was Kanal geraten sind und wie unsinnig das ist,
was sie da alle sagen.
Deswegen würde ich schon nochmal gerne an das Zitat von Donald Trump gehen.
Dem wurde ja gesagt, was hältst du davon, das zu begrenzen?
Und dann hat er geantwortet, whoever wins AI, wins.
Und ich glaube, da könnte man doch durchaus auch nochmal sich ein paar Gedanken dazu machen.
Weil damit meint er ja im Prinzip, weniger,
was weiß ich, den Wettkampf unbedingt jetzt zwischen Anthropic oder OpenAI oder
wem auch immer, als wahrscheinlich den zwischen den USA und China.
Weil wir so diese, den kriegerischen Teil, die die militärische gezielt nicht
moralischen Prinzipien unterliegende Nutzung noch ein bisschen ausgeklammert hatten.
Krieg ist ja eher dein Thema.
Ja, also ich meine, die Sichtweise gibt es und die ist in gewisser Hinsicht auch nachvollziehbar.
Ich meine, es ist nun mal wirklich eine Schlüsseltechnologie,
das lässt sich einfach nicht von der Hand weisen.
Ich weiß, es gibt auch viele Asketen, nicht nur im Softwarebereich,
sondern generell, die der Meinung sind, man müsste dieses Thema nur ausreichend
verschweigen, vermeiden und nichts davon benutzen, dann würde es schon irgendwie wieder,
weggehen und jeder, der das auch irgendwie nur anfasst oder sein Episodenbild
mit einem Bildgenerator,
generiert,
macht sich strafbar am Untergang der Menschheit.
Ja, kann man so sehen, aber halte ich wenig von, weil,
man muss sich halt jetzt schon mal auch damit auseinandersetzen,
weil wenn wir irgendeine Chance haben wollen, an diesem Diskurs in irgendeiner Form noch,
mitzuwirken, dann ist halt mal wieder ein tiefes Verständnis erforderlich und da hilft einfach,
eigene Erfahrung definitiv schon mal eine Menge.
Ja und am Ende hilft vielleicht auch KI, weil das ist halt nun mal.
Wir hatten das glaube ich auch schon mal, klingt ein bisschen einfach der Vergleich, aber,
ähnliches dachte man halt auch mit dem Rechnen und der Taschenrechner war dann
genauso so ein Teufelswerkzeug und der Computer dann natürlich auch auf jeden Fall.
Mittlerweile hat man sich daran gewöhnt, dass man eben Mathematik einfach mal
so absitzt. Man muss jetzt nicht unbedingt jedes Detail kennen,
wenn man da jetzt nicht gerade tiefes Verständnis sucht und forscht und so weiter.
Völlig okay ist, das zu machen. Nur, das ist halt etwas, wo man eben sieht,
wir können das eben mit Software besser machen und deswegen geschieht es halt auch einfach.
Und jetzt sind wir halt auf diesem nächsten Level, dass,
Bestimmte Dinge, von denen wir eben geglaubt haben, sie wäre bisher nur den
Hirnen vorbehalten, sich jetzt eben mit Software auch machen lassen und deswegen
werden sie auch getan werden.
Und da wird sehr viel Unfug bei rauskommen. Wir haben auch Gefährdungen,
aber auf der anderen Seite ist es auch ein Bereich, aus dem sehr viele positive
Entwicklungen kommen werden.
Es ist nicht nur so, dass AI uns alle umbringen wird, sondern es kann uns auch genauso gut retten.
Einige von uns will es am Leben lassen. Für die ist es super.
Freude, der muss auch mal gönnen können. Ja, kann ja nicht immer alles für alle sein.
Keine Ahnung, welche Krankheiten ich vielleicht noch entwickeln werde in Zukunft,
für die es dann auch durch solche Technologien...
Für die anderen Leute eine Heilung haben.
Ja, ist ja... Ich will jetzt nichts vorhersagen, was passiert,
aber ich halte das alles für sehr gut möglich, weil das, was es eben braucht,
im Forschungsbereich, nämlich viele Daten miteinander zu vergleichen und daraus
Schlüsse zu ziehen, das ist nun mal etwas, was man eben mit diesen Werkzeugen gut machen kann.
Dass es nicht immer alles richtig sein wird und dass es einen natürlich auch
in die Sackgasse führen kann, vollkommen klar und dass auch Leute damit irgendwie
dann einen biologischen Krieg planen wollen,
ja auch, es ist halt all of the above und damit müssen wir irgendwie klarkommen.
Deswegen müssen wir uns damit auseinandersetzen und diese Diskussion am Leben
erhalten. Das ist eigentlich auch so das, was wir jetzt eigentlich hier mit
diesem Segment so ein bisschen tun wollen. Haben wir schon ein paar Mal gemacht,
aber hilft natürlich, denke ich, auch das weiterhin zu tun.
Ich,
Es ist, ich hoffe, dass jetzt, also ich hoffe, dass diejenigen,
die dann am Ende wütende Kommentare schreiben, das will ich so ein bisschen
mal zu Ende gehört haben, was wir hier sagen.
Ich würde sehr gerne noch so ein bisschen darauf, also ich, wir haben jetzt
mal diesen, wovor waren die Leute, was ist der schlechte Pfadteil erklärt?
Oder ein bisschen beleuchtet, was heißt erklärt?
Wie du aber gerade auch schon saß, es gibt eine ganze ganze Menge an guten Dingen,
die man damit machen könnte.
Und es besteht natürlich auch Hoffnung, dass man diese guten Dinge macht.
Und ich würde insgesamt auch denken, bisher haben wir als Menschheit meistens,
die Kurve gekriegt, uns nicht auszulöschen, nicht vollständig, ja.
Immer nur so massenhafte Morde an bestimmten Bevölkerungsgruppen.
Die kamen aber von uns, die kamen von den Menschen.
Vielleicht kommen wir irgendwann dann doch, vielleicht ist das die Utopie,
die hier dann ins Haus steht, dass wir dann irgendwann uns doch alle erkennen,
dass der wahre Feind woanders ist und wir unsere Brüder und Schwestern,
von anderen Kontinenten mit anderen Hautfarben oder auch einfach nur von nebenan,
als Verbündete sehen sollten.
Aber dass hier diese Warnungen oder diese Doomsday-Szenarien bei dieser Technologie
auch diskutiert werden, ist sicherlich im weitesten Sinne sinnvoll.
Also, dass man sich darüber Gedanken macht.
Aber eben mit einem klaren Kopf. Und da stören mich einige Aufarbeitungen, die dann eben sehr,
dramatisierend sind oder sehr,
herunterspielend. Die gehören einfach zu dem Spektrum.
Keiner von beiden würde ich jetzt notwendigerweise mich verschreiben. Was meinst du?
Ich muss es für mich nochmal kurz wiederholen, bevor ich qualifiziert...
Also meine Frage an dich, Tim, ist, wo siehst du dich in fünf Jahren?
Siehst du dich in fünf Jahren? Siehst du dich in fünf Jahren?
Wenn ich jetzt sage, dass ich daran glaube, dass in fünf Jahren noch alles gut
ist, glaubt mir doch eh wieder keiner.
Aber ich meine, goldenen Zwanziger sind dann auf jeden Fall durch.
Also dann ist, dann liegt alles auf dem Tisch, Tim.
Ja.
Dann wird,
Dann ist Judgment Day, was ja übrigens der Titel von Zeit und Terminator Film ist.
Gut.
Anschließend an diese Diskussion wollen wir auch mit einem neuen Ding,
was wir uns ausgedacht haben,
gerade weil das manchmal auch so schwierig ist, da so die richtige Linie zu finden.
Da muss man dann auch einfach mal so ein bisschen zurückfragen.
Und das wollen wir tun mit einem neuen Format, über das wir nachgedacht haben.
Und das ist kein Format, was ihr euch herunterladen könnt, sondern das ist ein
Format, an dem ihr teilnehmen könnt.
Allerdings nur ein paar von euch.
Weil wir das in einem sehr kleinen Rahmen platen. Und das haben wir genannt,
den Logbuch Netzpolitik Salon.
Sprich, sprich, sprich. Spannend, ich will jetzt... Wann, wo, wie?
Genau.
Der Salon ist ein Treffen, wo wir uns mit euch treffen wollen.
Und das machen wir in Berlin, und zwar am 11.
Oktober dieses Jahres, also bald.
Und dort möchten wir, also wir werden da keine Sendungen aufnehmen, da wird auch,
nichts aufgezeichnet, nichts gestreamt, sondern es soll einfach ein Treffen
werden, aber jetzt in dem Sinne auch kein Hörertreffen, sondern wir möchten
gerne dort in die Diskussion kommen mit euch.
Und das heißt, es wendet sich jetzt an Leute, die nicht nur zuhören wollen,
sondern die vielleicht auch,
sagen wir mal, konkrete Fragen haben oder Redebeiträge haben,
zu den Themen, die wir hier normalerweise behandeln oder vielleicht behandeln sollten.
Sag mal wo.
In der Äh-Stube in Neukölln, in der,
müsste Fulda-Straße sein.
Wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Das ist eine relativ kleine, sehr gemütliche Kneipe, hat einen schönen Kamin.
Vielleicht ist der an, wenn es da kalt ist, ist ja Oktober.
Hat eine Bar, hat eine Toilette und insgesamt einfach eine ganz nette heimelige Atmosphäre.
Weil das, und wir haben es auch extra gewählt, weil es klein ist,
weil wenn wir jetzt eine Großveranstaltung machen würden, dann kann man ja auch nicht ins Gespräch,
Aber wir werden deshalb auch quasi eine Art Vorverkauf machen,
einfach um sicherzustellen, dass da nicht am Ende viel zu viele Leute vor der Tür stehen.
Es ist also eher so ein bisschen Crowd-Control,
und auch die Möglichkeit für euch zu wissen, sicher zu wissen,
dass ihr da dann auch hin und rein kommt.
Diesen Vorverkauf werden wir zeitnah launchen.
Es geht jetzt auch nicht um das große Geld. Es geht einfach eher um so ein Commitment.
Ja, okay, ich habe ein Ticket gekauft.
Wenn ich das jetzt nicht in Anspruch nehme, gebe ich es weiter und so weiter.
Wenn ihr jetzt irgendwie plant, von weit her anzureisen, würde ich vielleicht
bei der ersten Iteration nicht notwendigerweise euch das nahelegen.
Das ist ein Sonntag, später Nachmittag, Abend.
Und es ist auch ein Testballon. Wir gucken mal, wie das so läuft.
Wir gucken mal, wie das klappt, was sich da findet.
Wir haben aber durchaus vor, das oder ähnliche oder andere Formate ein bisschen
regelmäßiger zu machen im kleinen Kreise und so ein bisschen,
diese Sprechschuld abzubauen. Wir haben hier viel geredet und man soll ja auch mal zuhören.
Und wir sind an diesem Austausch sehr interessiert.
Genau, also könnt ihr euch das mal in den Kalender markieren. Neukölln, Ässtube, 11.
Oktober, irgendwie so auf einen späten Nachmittag, Frühjahr,
Abend und wir werden dann in den nächsten Sendungen hier weitere Informationen dazu geben.
Genau.
In der Woche davor ist auch noch ein kleiner Termin.
Den haben wir, glaube ich, auch noch nicht angekündigt. Das sind die D-Days Hamburg 2026.
Und zwar ist ja der DIT auf dem CCC-Kongress letztes Jahr,
ausgerufen worden. Wir haben ja wirklich.
Eine irre Verbreitung dieser Events überall, auch über Deutschland hinaus, in Europa gesehen.
Und der Hamburger CCC, der CCC-HH, macht jetzt zusammen mit der Wauholland-Stiftung vom 2.
Bis 4. Oktober zusammen mit Hamburger Stadtteil-Initiativen,
Hacker und Makerspaces und anderen zivilgesellschaftlichen Organisationen,
die ersten Digital Independence Days in Hamburg.
Der 4. Oktober ist ja wieder ein DIT. Das ist ja der Sonntag,
der erste Sonntag im Monat.
Und dann geht es aber dann schon am Freitag um 16 Uhr los. Samstag ist von 12
bis 21 Uhr Programm und Sonntag von 12 bis 17 Uhr.
Halt mal einfach ein bisschen größeres,
oder ein bisschen ausgeprägteres Zusammentreffen zu diesen Themen.
Mit dem Ziel, Kompetenz, Mündigkeit im Umgang mit moderner Technik zu vermitteln.
Und das finde ich ganz schön.
Und da glaube ich, wenn ihr in der Region beheimatet seid oder da für dieses
Event anreisen wollt, ist das sicherlich eine tolle Gelegenheit.
Alright, das war es dann auch für uns.
Wir sollten uns ja auf den Zusammenbruch vorbereiten und da könnt ihr schon mal.
Exiting on a high note, mein Freund.
Achso.
Wird schon alles gut werden. Bestimmt.
Es hätten ja alles hier heute gegangen.
Okay, Leute, das war's von uns.
Nächste Sendung dann gute Nachrichten.
Echt?
Ja, kennst du, das hängt doch auch so in vielen Kneipen. Freiwill ist alle oder
freiwillig morgen wieder oder so.
Mal gucken, ob das nicht wieder eine leere Versprechung ist.
Tschüss, Leute. Bis bald.
Ciao, ciao.